it looks like Justin Bieber had a blast
mixing and mingling at Coachella
Justin stepped out for a weekend in the
desert with wife Haley Bieber and
documented the couple's exciting
adventures at the Music Fest the couple
ran into some old and new friends on day
one justin was spotted supporting Powell
Jaden Smith at his said where he sported
hot pink hair and had his sister Willow
Smith opened his show with an epic
aerial stunt then the Biebs reunited
with his and Hayley's mutual friend
Kendall Jenner here's a pic of the model
pals repping Justin's new fashion line
rockin matching drew house bandanas
Kendall commented under JB's photo gangs
back did you meet the Biebs did he meet
Justin Bieber not me Justin Bieber or
what though dude people man people keep
playing with me cuz I'm they're like so
you shouldn't well one month later it
finally happened a Billy
Eilish met her idol Justin Bieber the 17
year old singer and 25 year old popstar
were spotted greeting each other with
hugs
Justin captioned the moment so this
happened a long and bright future ahead
of you this comes one day after Billy
received praise from mrs. Bieber on
social media after Billy put on to
showstopping performances including a
cameo with Cali for their song lovely
let's welcome Billy
[Music]
and I witnessed lzt the VIP section at
Billy solo show was packed
Billy was running late for her set our
insider says fans went nuts when she
finally hit the stage we have a feeling
this is only the beginning of an ongoing
friendship for Bieber and Billy the two
sing and dance at Ariana Grande set
which featured a suprise cameo by NC
[Music]
you